[Music]
in good-hearted prank news oh I love
this I love this you know what this one
is what you know what it is
Oh No oh ho stuff I've been into it
lately what the [ __ ] during this day
because her shoulders are so puffy yeah
good news like you know that's also why
I like coming here cuz I like I have
anxiety so I've been dodging the news
lately I know I know [ __ ] up news here
I'm ready for it but I get to talk to
you guys and it's light-hearted and it's
nice but we wait because we make laughs
we make fun of it yes yeah later though
but I'm a farmer you laugh not cry later
yeah okay it's submitted by call me
daddy okay wait okay all right okay man
is getting tens of thousands of birthday
calls after his son's post his phone
number on a billboard
oh sure that is cute though kind of tens
of thousands that's a lot yes
why could he he's he's like lonely I
call my dad it's his birthday this is
the billboard looks like my dad needs a
girlfriend this is
looks like wish my dad happy birthday
love your son oh my gosh dad looks like
a bounty hunter you received a sack of
badass that bullets older than is dead
no that's him okay whatare picture I'll
tell you why that doesn't make any sense
the dad got a text from a stranger he
was like hey happy birthday and then he
was like oh it's so cute and then he was
like oh this is Nick and then the dad
was like who's Nick and then he was like
well you don't know me but I saw a no
wait what was it you don't know me but I
wanted to wish you happy birthday he was
like wait how did you get my number just
like I saw her on a billboard
yeah then he rushed over to the
billboard took this photo sent it to his
kids like what the [ __ ] for real I loved
his face so cuz this face is like are
you [ __ ] kidding me yeah he doesn't
look happy at all
he's like you [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] well
anyways supposed to be for you to get
out of [ __ ] debt and you're using it
on this I don't know Jin Eun answer my
question why the sons on the dad's
billboard who's that the same person
well that's the same person it's just
one has a goatee one does hey why are
you so cool you look older than himself
it's a good beat this man runs two
companies David all right this cannot
get past the information I was already
told twice hold on why is the sky blue
why it takes two of us to be one brain I
do agree with that dude - I'm just
[ __ ] in different ways and I can see
that work cuz I'm talking about myself
okay
okay so this takes place in New Jersey
in case you guys are curious
Joisey we could have guessed that
anything
yes based on the dads look yeah oh
that's true I was thinking more Texas
but like I could see Jersey true let's
see it drives trucks related yeah it's
the leather jacket I think oh yeah it is
leather what a nice full beard it looks
like a nice guy though he does like a
you could see him hands in the
reflection of his sunglasses taking this
but at least he did it the long way to
true landscape all right so he said that
you he's received like an insane amount
of text messages and phone calls from
people all over the world because
someone posted this oh no yeah and it's
pretty really viral
it has clogged his phone like he cannot
use his phone so he's celebrating his
62nd birthday can I text him right now
what if he probably if we wait what if
we call it and see if you change this
number by now
whoa let's try it let's do it can I take
it off you're gonna call it let's do it
all right but yeah I mean like let's see
what it's what it's sad imagine at the
end of the article it said please you
guys don't call who'd it on speaker
that's okay they knew what they were
getting into when they call it a say hi
happy birthday report that he changed
his voicemail to say like hey thanks for
wishing me a happy birthday or whatever
so he you just have this day Lisa full
okay yeah all their that area that
episode big morning put on speaker you
too loud
we're the answer they say we wish you
had a birthday yeah
I'm just kidding news I wanted at least
the voicemail people that's amazing
after this video is gonna get another
like hundred thousand calls happy
birthday Kris
oh he's gonna curse us out Evan so do
you know what I'm doing another I've got
business calls coming in your
[ __ ]
Jersey yeah oh yeah so his two sons they
live in Florida and so they spent two
thousand dollars to put up a billboard
where he's dabbling they must have been
cracking up the entire hi brothers
thought of the idea and told the other
brother the other brother didn't even
answer you was just laughing I would
have been dying in tears I would be like
oh my god I can't believe we're gonna do
this I read laughing all the time
that's a changes number now but he's
probably too lazy to do that you will
you think I'll just keep it they have
that billboard for a whole month
and so it's get all passes birthday and
so there's I think people were doing
this this pictures of viral people are
still gonna call it though oh yeah
forever
you need the bub of the booth and that
sucks so if I was or just change my no
they probably they probably gave him
like a second phone or something like if
they can't drop two thousand on a
billboard they'll be like alright dad
you know we'll get you a phone here's a
burner phone yeah burner phone that's
crazy
your birthday phone is your burner phone
we should go to Miami I wanna call
another man I never been my mom went
like three times already you know Miami
is like great out and lived there but
it's really great to visit it's like
nice beach weather
beach weather just big booty [ __ ]
it's the way that MPM TV made me think
it is is it like for spring break yeah
that's the wild thing like you go there
and it's like okay what the [ __ ] this is
fantastic
you know Scarface yeah even a tight
without the beaches yeah that's what it
is
oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] like that yeah but
you guys do have the drink though cuz
that's the part I like I think when I
think Miami I think Miami Vice Scarface
cocaine and Versace that's what I think
it's old
I think steroids they're - they're like
Jack Jack Jack so it's like definitely
like I usually don't feel like I have to
work out somewhere but now you feel
that's like the biggest pool party
culture - most of the dudes are on gear
yeah you feel like I got a crazy dude
and all the girls are [ __ ] fit and
[ __ ] and they're like [ __ ] one of the
sweater yeah you lost me huh why cuz all
the girls are fit yes we have until
summer to make sure that we get to that
point no and then will we come back I
just gained 40 pounds this guy take a
lot of steroids before I get there when
I think of Florida like Miami I think of
Florida man like every bad party hand
I've ever read about is a subculture
it's just a party area it's a touristy
area like no but it's scary that we
could have an entire JK Newsday about
like Florida people you know we learned
being honest you told us know someone I
think it was maybe kalila or Bobby or
someone no I forgot someone said it
sounds excellent kalila [ __ ] Florida the
reason why we get so much news from
Florida is because they have this law
where they're they there's their phone
so I think they're pretty much fully
transparent with news and they don't
have to be filtered through the police
department first so a lot of other
states the police get a hold of like the
the incident and then they have to go
okay is this ready to be released to the
public because it might affect our
investigation and then so because of
that it's it's slower to leak out got it
this is what Florida the minute it like
the incident happens the police and the
reporters can run oh yeah arrive then
maybe just start putting the story out
deaths every day in LA yeah cuz a buddy
of ours what you guys home to but he was
telling us that
in because he moved the DTLA and there
was a cot that told him that in that
area alone he goes he'll see in his
high-rise building like people getting
shot whatever and like how come this
stuff isn't a noose he goes well in LA
like 60 70 people getting shot a day so
you have they pick and choose which one
you could see like for example just this
past weekend somebody at Smorgasburg LA
fell off a building committed suicide in
killers anywhere I was it happened right
after I left that's [ __ ] crazy so I
was like okay I kind of wanted to find
out details so I was looking it up
not a single news article about Oh 60
people a day are the game it was like
some kind of ridiculous number but
somebody's getting stabbed shot killed
something I mean if you think about LA
County that's 10 million people yeah so
just statistically it makes sense yeah
it just makes sense like numbers-wise
just like just like everyday people yeah
I mean but not all I was just deaths
right it's not murders it's not suicide
there might be just natural gas there
might be other people yeah there's just
a lot of deaths like for example he was
telling us the other day there was like
this Carl's jr. right at the corner and
this dude just walked in to start
stabbing the [ __ ] out of people was even
on the news like literally walking
around stabby and the cops came woman
they had to shoot him take him down
wasn't on the news
I knew he just happened the day before I
got there mm-hmm where isn't downtown LA
yeah I want to go home is bliss I bet
you that's it
jr. really called surreal it great [ __ ]
goes down wherever you're at but it's
just like this like whenever I move into
a new city I look at the city's police
report I don't there's always gonna be
murder
that's rape all that stuff not able to
South Pasadena if there's it's book it's
not as bad but it still happens you need
to be rich still over there but it's
people dying off and drinking like a
vegan smoothie I was worried about the
lettuce and now you guys are telling me
at any given point I could piece you
know you know lettuce has like it why me
raaah can fall down smash on the head
the one that looks really loose right
there oh that's a camera thing tilt it
was ribbed it is some answers do a
[ __ ] backflip in you get [ __ ] up
there